Hello everybody. It's great to see so
many of you who are still here at the
final on final day right at the end. So
I hope you all had a great conference.
Show of hands, who here uses GitHub
Copilot?
Awesome. Lovely stuff.
Who here uses VS Code with GitHub
Copilot?
Awesome. So I'm going to be talking
about both these things today. I'm going
to be talking about cooking with agents
in VS Code. Now gentleman before was
speaking about cognitive load of agents
and that is absolutely correct. You see
so many different things now with agents
and they're popping up all over the
place from the CLI, in the terminals, in
chat windows, in other editors, etc.
etc. But we still somehow seem to find
ourselves in this sort of paradigm where
everybody thinks agents can solve the
world's problems. You still see
developers and I still speak to folks
who think we can do one shot prompts.
They'll create a wonderful application
or solve all of their issues in one go.
Absolutely not the case. And we end up
asking these questions from a business
perspective of what's the ROI, what's
the productivity boost, where are we
seeing our money? And at the moment
we're seeing this whole expenditure on
AI and all of this infrastructure, all
of these sort of toolings and services
and we're still yet to really reap the
benefits of those services.
So when we look at how people are
spending and how businesses are looking
at AI, we really need to be very careful
with how we're utilizing the tools and
services. We need to be careful about
token spend. We need to be understanding
the tools and the flexibility. I read
somewhere yesterday on LinkedIn somebody
has released this repo. It's growing
massively in popularity and it's talking
like a pirate for your your chatbots to
talk back to your your AI services and
language models to talk about that
because it reduces the token spend. Now
people are coming up with these really
intuitive and really fun ways to get
around token expenditure and really pull
in those benefits
very quickly.
So what I'm going to be talking about is
GitHub Copilot agents. Now this doesn't
just apply to GitHub Copilot, this also
applies to other AI agents as well. So
when we're looking at Copilot agents
around context, what they really have
access to in your workspaces, how
they're being used and utilized from
within VS Code and the CLI, we're going
to be looking at all of those things
very shortly.
So just a plain and simple, what kind of
agents do we have at the moment? Now
we're looking at local agents. We've got
local agents which are in VS Code. You
may use Claude, you may use all these
other AI services. Still applicable,
still running on your local machine with
remote models, anything that you're
already using, maybe you're using
locally hosted ones as well. But this is
a way to have
local models interacting with you side
by side, very hands-on, very much in the
context and human in the loop.
Then you've got
background agents. Now we use the GitHub
Copilot CLI. We have also got access to
that within VS Code.
But this is more of an isolated way to
be using them. Now we are actually using
Git worktrees. Show of hands if you know
what Git worktree is and who uses them.
Awesome, wonderful. For those of you who
don't know,
easy way to explain that is it is a
branch that is mapped to an isolated
folder within the workspace that you're
working in, like a subdirectory, just a
chop of your code with its own little
branch associated to it.
Very similar to a Git branch in general.
Then you've got cloud agents. Now cloud
agent is quite an interesting one
because it allows you to scale outside
of your organization very very quickly
and utilize a lot of the power of I
guess the cloud and some of the services
that we're using in GitHub. Now we use
these when we don't want to be touching
it ourself. I use this when it comes to
writing documentation or sort of having
less of a hands-on approach.
So when we when would we use a local
agent? Well I'd use a local agent when
it comes to writing tests. I want to be
really hands-on with my tests. I want to
understand what's going on in the code
base. I really want to be in there in
the weeds. When would I use a background
agent? Well a background agent would be
great if I want to be sort of a 50/50. I
want to create a UI for a front end of
an application. I kind of want to know
what's going on. I don't really want to
hand it off to a cloud agent because I
don't want to be fully out of the loop,
but I also also don't want to really be
hands-on to and fro myself because that
can take time. That can be quite
arduous, that can be quite annoying.
So I would use a background agent and
I'm going to show you how I'm using
Autopilot to do exactly that with GitHub
Copilot in just a moment.
When would I use a cloud agent? Well I
would use that mostly for documentation.
I hate documentation. I don't like
writing it. I don't think many people do
unless you're a content developer.
I really just pawn that off to the cloud
agents. And that could be making a
repository open source friendly, it
could be writing a readme using some
skills to do that as well.
So what I'm really looking at is VS Code
as a single entry point for AI agents.
We have got third party support, we have
got background, we've got local and
we've got remote entry points for all of
these agents. So the ultimate what we're
trying to do is understand where
you are sitting as a developer and how
easy we can make it for you to use these
agents to reduce that cognitive load.
Seems quite complicated but it's
actually really straightforward. So I'm
going to show a video now. I was going
to do this live but I don't really think
I'm going to have time to do all of this
live. So I'm going to whiz through this
video.
So I'm going to start with a very simple
Python application. This is just a CRUD,
well create, read, update and delete,
just a very simple product store. Not
very pretty, not very good. As you can
see, pretty straightforward. What I
actually want to do is create a front
end UI for it. So I've got a ticket up
in GitHub and I'm saying hey this is
wonderful, go and add a front end, we
need some more prettiness here. We need
it to look good. So I'm going to say
summarize and plan a solution to issue
25. Now you'll notice I'm actually using
a CLI background agent at this point.
Now I'm using that because I want it to
be sort of hands-on hands-off, a little
bit of understanding what it's doing.
Also don't really care if it messes
things up, it can go and iterate. I'm
also going to be using Autopilot. Now
Autopilot is currently in preview and
this just means it's not going to ask me
a bunch of questions if it wants to do a
bunch of tool calls. Great, wonderful,
can be very dangerous.
Use at your peril, right? Don't don't
just abuse that one.
Um but I'm using it here to create a
plan. I don't want it to ask me every
single time I want it to do an STP call.
So I'm then saying wonderful, here's the
plan. Now start it, but before you
create a pull request because on
Autopilot it will do a pull request,
stop and pause and let me test locally.
Whilst off doing its lovely stuff, I can
then move on to my next stage where I'm
going to be using another kind of agent.
So I'm just going to go and leave that
one behind. Let's go and spin up a new
chat and let's go and start a cloud
agent. I've noticed that this is not a
very open source friendly repository. I
want this to be
have a readme or have have a
contribution guidelines, have all this
all these readmes I really want as an
open source project. So I'm going to
pull on and say hey go and make this
open source friendly, add all the
necessary files for it.
Don't really care.
Now as a developer I can go into my code
base and start poking around. I've
noticed that I don't have any tests. So
I'm going to go check out and I've
noticed there is a custom agent
available for me in VS Code.
This custom agent is just essentially
explaining and showing how to be using
or how to write
test cases for this Python application.
So what I can do now is start spinning
up a local
agent.
So just like that at the very bottom I
can click local. I'm going to select
Claude Opus 46. I'm going to have medium
reasoning. I want it to be kind of fast.
I don't really care for it too much.
It's got a great understanding in this
custom agent. Go and write some unit
tests.
Now as a developer I can still skim
through. I've got very much a hands-on
to and fro with a local agent. I've got
a remote agent doing some work for me
and I've got a background agent creating
a new front end.
So here I can see right it's written
some tests. It's going to go ahead and
try and
run them. It's passing the tests.
But I've also noticed that there's some
other problems in the code. It's not
very friendly. The errors that are
coming back are not wonderful. So I'm
going to say go and update the error
handling on the routes and update the
tests as well. So you can see I've got a
lot of to and fro with this local agent.
I've got my remote agent working and
I've got my background agent working all
simultaneously.
So whilst that's gone off and working, I
can go and check out what my other
agents are actually up to.
So as it's working through this you can
see Copilot is just going to be skimming
through. I didn't actually speed up some
of this video. This is all pretty quick.
I did this pretty pretty quickly
with these agents. There you go, you can
see some of the code is updated. We've
got the new tests, we've got the code
updated. Let's go and check out the
background agent. That has now finished.
Which is cool. Let's go and check on the
remote agent. How's the remote agent
getting on?
Well actually this is the this is the
test. Run the test. The tests have
passed. That is the local agent. That's
now finished.
Now I can go and check out my
remote agent.
So as we're walking through this we can
see as a developer I've got very much
hands-on hands-off. I'm working with
multiple agents simultaneously. We can
see where they're running all within
this single context of VS Code. Now if I
go and look on the pull requests
extension in VS Code, we can see that
I've now got a pull request. Now this is
one that I previously brought earlier.
The one that's running in the chat is
actually taking quite a while, but
the principle still stands. It's running
all these different agents at the same
time.
So, all I really want to do now is go
and check out
my background agent. I want to go see it
working. I want to go see this new front
end that I've just created.
Now, I asked it to pause before I pushed
over a pull request and tell me how to
test it.
So, I'm going to say, "Well, actually,
the way you were telling me how to test
that is wrong."
So, I've still got hands-on, hands-off.
It's more of 50/50. I'm saying, "This is
working in a Git work tree. How do I
actually run this?" And remember, this
is what it currently looks like as an
application.
So, I'm going to go check out the new
directory, which is a Git work tree.
I'm then going to run this Python
application. You'll see a very drastic
change between what is created in my
single directory versus what I currently
have.
And there is a port conflict here.
Uh
So, hurry up and run that.
There we are.
So, if I click that, this is the new
product demo. Now, this is the third
agent that I'm running simultaneously,
and that is essentially a great way of
how you're using different agents within
one context to kick it all off using
GitHub Copilot. That's new error
checking, and that is how I've been
using multiple agents. So, one code
base,
three problems, three separate agents
fixed all at the same time. The local
agent was writing my test for me because
I wanted hands-on. I really wanted human
in the loop. I used my background agent
to write the front end because I don't
really care
what it does. It's quite an arduous
task. It's quite big. It's quite
time-consuming.
And then I used my cloud agent to write
my documentation for me. So, all in all,
that's a pretty successful run.
So, how are cloud agents actually
working? Because I get this question
quite a lot. How much is it going to
cost? How is it working? What are they
doing? And how do I get them running?
Well, they're actually running in GitHub
Actions. They're pretty safe and secure
because they're running in a isolated
environment. They have got extended
context through MCP servers. Who here
uses MCP servers just out of curiosity?
Awesome. So,
cloud agent actually has access to the
GitHub MCP server and the Playwright MCP
server, so you can do testing with
screenshots. You can do automated
front-end testing.
And you can obviously write your
workflows. You've got
um
the the dynamic workflows now. And it
has got built-in safeguards. So, you've
got network firewalls. You don't want
this agent talking to a whole bunch of
different things. It's absolutely
white-listed and restricted. It also
doesn't have access to your main branch.
Therefore, you're not able to push
directly to your main branch. It's very
much restricted in that sense, so it is
very safe to use.
Now, I mentioned earlier, this is very
much GitHub Copilot, but it is not just
GitHub Copilot that this applies to.
This actually uses all the same concepts
across all different AI agents
uh that you can use. So, custom
instructions very much defining how the
agent is running. You've got custom
agents, which is what I showed you today
in that short demo,
where you're able to use very specific
agents to tackle certain problems, I
fixing test cases or writing test cases.
You have prompt files, which will help
you with your prompting, and agent
skills. Agent skills is more of like the
the newer version of agents.md. There's
always like a new thing that's coming on
every single week now. So, all of this
is actually applicable to GitHub Copilot
as well as other AI services, too.
Now, inside VS Code, this is a modal
which is very recent, and I can jump out
of the slides in just a moment to show
you exactly um how this looks.
So, if I was to go over to VS Code, open
up my GitHub Copilot chat pane, and if I
click the cog up here, you can actually
see
everything that I have in one user space
for you to customize the chat and the
agents that you are running. So, whether
you've got agents, I've got my custom
test agent. I've got my built-in agents,
which is ask, explore, and plan. I've
got some skills. So, this is essentially
what some of the VS Code team sort of
pre-empted you to be using here. So,
you've got some extensions. You've got
address a PR comments. You've got create
pull request. You can jump into these
and edit them as you wish. And this is
just intuitive skills that we have
popped in there for you. I don't have
any instructions, but this is where
you'd have your instructions file, your
prompts if you've got any built-in
prompts like creating an agent, just
different prompts that can then go off
and kick off at skills. You've got
hooks. Yeah, I don't have any hooks on
this one, but a very good example if you
wanted to create or configure some
hooks, you can do so with uh Copilot
inside VS Code and any MCP servers as
well. So, you kind of have this whole
control plane in this modal, which
allows you to control your agents and
chat customizations from within one
single place.
This isn't just confined. We have
third-party support as well. So, there
is Claude as uh down here, so you can
have access to all of your Claude things
uh and all your plugins,
uh hooks, instructions, and skills for
Claude, too. So, it's not just
restricted to VS Code and GitHub
Copilot.
So, if you want to get hands-on with
some of the uh skills or customizations,
we have got this awesome open-source
project which we're running. It's called
Awesome Copilot. It's
aka.ms/awesomecopilot.
Like I said, this is directed at
Copilot, but it's absolutely not just
for Copilot. You can use this and
massage them and use them for other AI
tooling as well cuz we do know that
people in the community use more than
just Microsoft things and GitHub things.
We also have an MCP server. So, if
anybody's interested in utilizing this
from their from their workflows from MCP
standpoint, we also have encapsulated
that into an MCP server.
For those of you don't know about MCP,
so the Mono Context Protocol is a great
way for you to get hands-on and extend
the uh LLMs that you're working with or
any of the chats customizations that you
have. For example, if you wanted Azure
or talk to your Azure resources or I
know GCP, AWS, etc., you can go through
an MCP. It'll obviously be locked down
by authentication. Uh but there's also
free ones as well and open ones which
don't require authentication like
Playwright and documentation ones, I
Microsoft Learn,
uh and so on and so forth.
So, just in time,
uh as a wrap-up, Visual Studio Code is a
single entry point for AI agents, and
we've really built this agentive
workflow around multiple different
services. We've got third-party plugins.
We've got first-party plugins. And we've
got the full spec support for MCP. We've
got chat customizations, and you can
connect to the GitHub Copilot CLI
sessions through VS Code. So, it's all
in one single sequential uh sequence for
you as a developer inside your workflow.
I would love to hear more about your
workflows and what you're using and the
agents and how you're using them after
the session because I believe I've only
got just less than a minute left. So,
thank you ever so much for listening,
and thank you very much for coming
today.